there was uh i think i think it may have
been keemstar i'm not sure a big
youtuber yeah
said the word e i'm gonna pause here
and girl okay i have to do a pause there
wait really you can't do
the them together because the youtube
algorithm for tracking speech
thought it was a dif it was a racial
slur oh really yeah because think about
what that
oh i put it together in my head that's
why i said i
said it in my head and i was like pause
and girl
as in female yes yes and and that was
enough and they got flagged for
because it came up in the captions hmm
what the heck
welcome to the world where robots don't
quite understand yeah robots don't know
what's offensive they don't know the
nuance of being human
that's right robots yes
what if whoa whoa whoa don't piss them
off lydia i mean
yes they're wonderful thank you wait
wait what if what if what we're going
through right now
is like skynet skynet yes the ai has
already taken over the internet has
become self-aware
and so it's feeding people all of these
things to get them really angry so they
fight
and then it takes over i don't know i
don't know i could see it the ai maybe
no you're right you know the scariest
thing about ai actually is
there's something even scarier it is
yeah that we
created algorithms to serve us
and we've created a vortex that's
flushing ourselves down the toilet yep
so here's the way i explain it before
it's like youtube created an algorithm
because they wanted to surface game of
thrones
they said content that is longer than 10
minutes that gets high retention
high engagement that's the content we
want to see
they looked at game of thrones and said
look at this people watch on average the
whole episode
they all give it positive remarks so
they all smash the like button
yeah they do oh yeah so when it's
happening
the content that gets promoted by the
algorithm has nothing to do with good
content it's just whatever fits into
these specific little
notches and then you ended up with these
weird videos of the hulk dancing with
hitler speaking children's songs
i'm not exaggerating no that's right we
did an episode yeah literally
that's what surfaced in the algorithm
craziness so think about how insane that
is and now i turn on amazon and it's
like you should watch this movie escape
from la which is a post-apocalyptic
dystopian movie
and then i see dan bongino tweeting
about snake
snake pliskin and that's the character
from the movie and i'm like
did amazon tell him to watch this too
definitely it did
i gotta get in touch with him dude i
turned on netflix
and it was like you should watch
contagion and i'm like
i know why you're recommending me that
yeah because of pandemic somebody
started watching it because of the
pandemic
and then netflix assumed people really
liked the movie started showing it to
everybody
then everybody watched it now everyone's
got pandemic on the mind yeah and that's
that's how we ended up manipulating
ourselves but the scary thing is
the algorithms were first created to be
like a tv guide almost
but now we are being guided there's no
one in control of the algorithm anymore
it's just spinning us in circles and
everybody's going nuts
you watch you watch videos on these on
on you watch movies about these
pandemics
and like we were talking about yesterday
people start viewing these fictional
realities as like real potential
realities
yeah and that's that's the real cycle is
when they they make that the new reality
then make a new story because the new
reality is are now it's boring
and now it doesn't excite you anymore
because that's what the their norm is
so they got to up up the level keep up
in the level upping the dosage upping
the dosage yes
exactly the dosage man people are
addicted to it
until you know what you're just left
with hate that's what
that's what we're seeing i really like
living on hate
in in in in in all seriousness i think
what we're really dealing with is that
we as humans have built these systems
all around us and now they're starting
to
you know fall in on each other like
dominoes yeah
and maybe after whatever happens happens
there's like a cleansing you know of
like
the chaos is washed away and something
new emerges i have no idea
but right now it feels like it feels
like if
it really does you know what i think
it's a bell curve there was there was
there was a graduate is the bell curve
well it is right
no you're right it's a gradual incline
of unified
world view very early on in human
existence
you had weak communication right yeah so
someone in some town 10 miles away had
no idea what was going on 10 miles away
from them
until someone went and communicated and
transferred that information so
the world views were actually separate
if you were to travel a thousand miles
to different country it was dramatically
different different food different
culture different
you know then communication started
becoming unified and we started going up
towards the top of that peak where it's
like unified communication and world
view
and control and control and now we're on
the back end
as the internet starts becoming more
prevalent people isolate themselves in
in the communities they choose
yeah whereas people used to watch the
news and the news would try to report
what was happening because they wanted
to reach a broad audience
now people choose what stories they read
that's a good point so instead of
learning about what's really happening
they specifically focus on
what they want to know what is antifa
doing right right
and i'm and i think or just whatever
fits their narrative
that makes them happy or keeps them
angry or whatever it is
their little bubbles think about it this
way i think we are part of the problem i
think
i am especially part of the problem okay
because we talk about things we find
interesting
that's a good point and because of that
and because we find culture more
interesting
we're more likely to be successful on
youtube okay which means we're more
likely to be recommended to more and
more people
okay now facebook is worse because
facebook has the direct share mechanism
so it's a hundred to a thousand times
fold more accelerated yeah
but as long as we and every other news
outlet and i think i think it's fair to
say the news outlets take the brunt of
the responsibility on this one because
they're well funded and they have they
employ teams of hundreds of people
yeah but so long as the algorithms prop
up
what we find interesting then the only
thing we'll ever watch is going to be
you know culture war stuff that shocks
and scares people yeah
and then we're so now we're going to the
back end of that curve where the unified
view is starting to fracture again
where we used to all agree on what was
happening now it's breaking apart and
moving back to a world where everyone
really believes different things
and different communities start emerging
it's not necessarily a bad thing in that
capacity
but it does mean people going to fight
yeah
and how do you have a i think we're
going to see something happen
this saturday yeah there's there's
tension in there
it's been around for a while and it's
been building and building gettysburg
and they're they're going to gettysburg
and it's like it's a famous spot it's
but here's a big they're announcing it
they're they're spreading they've
already yeah it's already been spread
around you know it's not just like
they're making a secret meeting
and they're gonna do it they're
announcing they're shoving it down
everyone's throat
we're going to go burn your flag on your
independence day
so you know yeah yeah fu
we're going to do it but now consider
this here we are
with about 34 000 people watching and
probably hundreds of thousands watch
you know the segment and the remaining
clip where we mentioned gettysburg and
then how many people are like i'm gonna
go now
you know what i mean just simply because
we talked about it because we were
interested in it yeah
and other people are interested in what
we say now the message of gettysburg is
spreading
and what if we just created a
self-fulfilling prophecy what if no one
was ever going to actually go to
gettysburg and they spread these memes
around but no one cared and all of a
sudden now we talk about it and all
sudden
there goes we have responsibility but
it's not it but
that's that's an impossibility that's
great because i've definitely thought
about this
right what responsibility do you have to
avoid important stories
right and not tell people what's
happening i'm like you have no i you
can't do that
yeah you can't withhold information from
people i don't believe you have the
right to do that
if antifa says they're going to
gettysburg to burn american flags i
think it's really important americans
know about this absolutely
i agree what if that contributes to the
severity of what happens
maybe you can't think about that yeah
and a lot of people even today
they're saying like because i've i've
been posting stuff on twitter about
chas is over they cleaned out jazz and
there's a
a lot of comments are like how come i
didn't how come i'm only seeing this
you'd think this would be like huge news
yeah nobody's reporting it yep
it's like interesting little bits but
you know i think it is
uh journalists report it okay but it's
whether or not the culture
the cultural institutions make it a
mainstream issue
so you will find a news article that
says jazz cleared out
right but will you find chris cuomo
ranting about it for an hour or don
lemon no definitely not
right rachel maddow think about what
happened in chaz with the 16 year old
getting killed
are you going to see that on prime time
for these big cable shows no tucker
carlson maybe
yeah and maybe that's why his ratings
are so high because he's actually
talking about things that people find
irrelevant
he does yeah and the other sides are the
other side is just you know what man
there are some uh political commentators
that i feel like are sitting in the
corner of the room not paying attention
yeah
and it's like we are all over on the
other side of the room and everyone's
arguing about the riots the chaos
the law the statues and then you have
some of these commentators
who these are these are people i think
are grifting
they know that if they stand for what's
morally just
which is liberty freedom civil rights
they would lose their audience it's true
because the left is happy about what
they're doing and doesn't want to hear
bad things about it
the statues must come down no no no no
in chaz that that kid was a murderer
they say and i've seen the posts from
the end of people they're saying things
like this kid
in the vehicle was actually shooting at
people and it's like you have no proof i
knew that happened why are you saying
that yeah
all we know is somebody killed this kid
yep so you have these that's their
argument for everything that they do
well this this well not not that it's
justified it's it's that
they are just saying blank blank
statements
with no proof no backing well this is
the case
man what do you got to say about that
and it's like well i have all this proof
here
and they're like oh why it's not i don't
want to see that but but not even this
is the case
it's not what it is but it's not even
that degree in the case of she has it's
we don't know what happened all i know
is a six-year-old kid a 16-year-old kid
was killed by the chad security why
all the evidence right and then they say
i know what really happened and i said
no you don't neither do i
right but the point i'm bringing up is
you've got these political commentators
that know
they can't take a principled stance so
i'm seeing posts from people where
they're like donald trump said what and
i'm like no one's talking about that
yeah like the the the journalists are
talking about the statues coming down in
columbus and in virginia they're talking
about the riots the protests covet
and and then there are some just
commentators that are like well i guess
i'll just talk about
trump saying naughty words again have
you heard the expression
the adults are talking now yeah cause i
really like that expression it's a
little condescending but it's like
yeah we're not talking about that right
a little bit yeah we're not talking
about donald trump
we're talking about things that are
actually affecting us in our like daily
lives
and not only that it's like what what
what is trump doing
nothing that i mean nothing it's like
bill barry should have statement on the
clearing out of jazz
the big cultural stories that i so so i
follow a wide group of people
i follow news organizations i follow
left and right and the most
common discussion amongst most people is
related to
ongoing protests and coveted okay
there's some conversation bubbling up in
the past couple weeks among politic like
hardcore politicos
who are more concerned about um the hill
like capitol hill yeah and so they're
talking about the russian bounty thing
yeah this whole thing and then there are
some people who just like orange man dad
trump said dumb things yeah and i'm like
i guess it's lowest common denominator
anti-trump stuff
yeah you don't got to raise a finger
really you don't got to talk about
difficult moral questions all you got to
do is say
dude you guys hear that like donald
trump is dumb like
can you believe it and i bet that would
get plenty of shares
breaking news donald trump is dumb yep
yeah
i mean i you know you go into facebook
and it's like that's what i see
and i'm just like yeah it's not relevant
it's not warranted like why
here's where is this information it's
like it's not information it's just a
meme
it's like if you've ever gone to uh like
a a
car like a trading card shop and like
listen to little kids talk about pokemon
cards yeah that's what it sounds like
there's like this naive ignorant
enthusiasm no offense i mean if you
if you're into a pokemon card game or
whatever it's fine the point i'm saying
is like how little kids approach it
like dude it's so cool like my dad he
got me a charizard it's first edition it
was like a hundred thousand dollars
no oh you're dead i swear my dad got it
and now you you take that mentality
and you go to these people who are
talking about trump it's like did you
hear that like
donald trump actually said uh he said
something about like how he likes white
people
no way did he swear he's so dumb and
you're like
what what is this like might as well be
grunting
smacking the ground with sticks that's
what they're doing
now don't get me wrong i mean they're
certainly you know hardcore trump
supporters are not all that bright
but i find when i when i was traveling
around the trump rallies in the last
election cycle
i did not come across i would say 95
percent of the people i came across were
trump supporters
were like regular people that you talked
to and they'd go so what do you do
i'd be like i'm a dress huh what does
that mean and then you talk and i'd be
like
it's like oh really well that sounds
nice you get to go to trap rails or
something
yeah so why do you like trump and
they'll give you some very basic bland
reason like
you know immigration is really important
to me or whatever there'd be a guy be
like well you know my factory shut down
and trump was talking about that
but you go to the left-wing rallies why
do you not like him
he's racist well i i
i was told not to he's racist yeah oh
that's probably there that's like
number one oh he's so racist yeah and
then when you ask him
what racist things have you done
i have to go yeah you'll hear you'll
hear things that are like
uh in my experience because i did go to
a handful of
i've been to a bunch of leftovers as
well as well
uh a couple bernie events and they'll
give you reasons why they like bernie
and that's the difference between the
crony establishment democrat people who
are just like orange man bad and can't
tell you what's going on right
versus the progressives who actually
know what they want and
will tacitly support the democratic
party for the time being or actually for
the most part won't
i find that actually when you talk to a
lot of the people who backed bernie they
don't care
they don't care about bernie no they
care about pushing the parties as far
left as possible because they're
socialists
that's true like if you if you look at
the project veritas releases
some of these people seem to be very
naive
when it comes to some of them yeah some
of them are really smart
some of them are manipulative and
they're well read and they understand
what they're doing because they want
power good point and they're willing to
do what they have to do to get it okay
and they'll manipulate stupid people to
get it i think there's
there's a smaller minority of that group
that are smart
than the ones that have no idea what
they're doing so here's the way i see it
there's a large portion of what i would
call the coalition voters
okay meaning politically independent
moderates disaffected liberals
and conservatives and many like die-hard
conservatives
yeah who will support trump on the left
you have establishment democrats who are
completely
naive and ignorant as to how politics
work and these are the people you'll see
on facebook who say things that make no
sense
and you'll try and talk to them and
they'll be like those make things up
they literally
it's it's they literally just make
things up yeah
then you have progressives who really
want idealistic policies
and they're probably not well read
enough to understand why some of these
things don't make sense
but they have a decent understanding of
at least their tribal
you know politics like what they want
and why they want it but they don't
understand how the machine doesn't make
sense
okay so that's what i see so i see a
tendency among the left
to have a fractured world view they
support censorship and then complain
when they get censored
you know what i mean yeah they support
they say they say just pay for it just
pay for school and they don't understand
how economic actually works it's like
the mayor in
seattle yeah go go have your summer of
love
the second you come to my block you're
done yeah and that's
exactly what happened i think there's a
lot of uh
there's a lot of conservatives who are
very very tribalist like a lot of trump
supporters are just like whatever trump
says
even if it's you know even if he changes
positions or and then there are actually
a lot of interestingly right now i'm
seeing a lot of trump supporters who are
actually angry
they're angry with republicans they're
angry with trump tucker carlson's a
great example he just did a segment
where he said
that the republicans keep offering up
symbolic victories that are meaningless
yep what did he say he was like why
should i care what was the in the
content of peter strzok's email
or text messages i don't want that
that's not a focus right now yeah how
does that how does that help
the working class right and this is what
we're talking about too like
yep so you have you have people who are
very tribal and willing to accept
symbolic victory
yeah then you have the far left that
wants tangible but pie in the sky things
and then you have people in the middle
who for the most part have a general
understanding of the nuance the balance
and are desperately trying to calm
everybody down within reason
or complaining about how crazy mostly
the left is
yeah well i mean we said it the other
day um when we were talking about the
people who were in charge
it's like those are the people that want
power republican
democrat it doesn't matter so the people
who are in the house yeah
fireworks i did have that yeah holy cow
i hope it was fireworks oh i was like
no that was that was a firework it did
sound echoey yeah yeah yeah
that was the firework it's july 1st it's
july 1st
this all makes sense people are proud to
be american that's right
they are going to light fireworks i got
to stop you the fourth of july would be
the perfect day for something crazy you
know what i'm
shooting people would think it's
fireworks people have no idea what's
happening
there could be gunshots going off and no
one would call the cops upstairs
what were you saying about they were
saying they're gonna go on the fourth of
july and shoot people or whatever
that's that's what's going around
they're spreading that word they're
scared to go around and shoot people no
one will call the police
everybody's armed now that's true
they're gonna get no one's killed
no one's expecting it if black-clad
dudes lurk through your neighborhood at
night
and you're in your backyard with your
friends and family and they
take out a rifle and as a bang no one
will call the police
i heard a bang the cops going to be like
you saw your fireworks i don't think it
was fireworks
it was probably fireworks well my uncle
larry here he's
he's bleeding to death now i mean i
don't think that was fireworks no i'm
talking about the neighbors
no i know so you'll be panicking being
like what happened it's kind of dark out
and someone falls down and you freak out
you call you say help help something's
happening he's bleeding
but no neighbors will come to your aid
so what if you're by yourself
yep sitting in your old barca lounger
that you got from a thrift store and
you're watching reruns of 1994
you know bulls the glory days and
somebody
you know shoots you no one will call
anybody oh man
no one will beat the back up another
firework went off this is depressing
i'm not saying i actually think
anything's going to happen but when you
when back i'm going to say what i
what i've always said there's a lot more
people that are ready for these
antifa folks than they think than they
think
then the antifa think that's what i'm
saying the antifa think that they've got
all the everybody wound around their
fingers that they can do whatever they
want
but they they're going to have a really
eye-opening experience when they
finally run into the people that are
like i'm just going to kill you
if you come in our neighborhood
so if if you're sleeping in your bed at
three in the morning uh-huh
and then somebody jimmy's your life you
can you can give me an example
i i don't want to i don't want to hear
your example of how it could go
sure tim how are you going to give me
are you going to give me an example of
everyone having an escape plan and a
tactical strategy for when they have no
idea what i'm
telling you i was just telling you what
i think the majority is there the
majority of people are
they're freaking out they're they were
having dinner they came out with guns
they're ready for it
people were buying guns flying off the
shelves
because of this because you are killing
people you're talking about
this tactical move on the 4th of july
when everyone's distracted to go around
shooting people
and everybody is can feel the tension in
the air
of course there's going to be an example
that someone can go at 3am and kill
somebody
all right problem is you're acting like
the people who are planning these
murders
wouldn't actually have a plan for it
would be like i'm going to randomly walk
into someone's yard while they're
barbecuing and start shooting
no they're going to be like everyone's
on edge i understand that and i'll adapt
my strategy accordingly sure
so anyway the point is we just heard a
big bang
and we were all like what was that what
was that and then i realized i was like
whoa that thing you know you were saying
there's rumors going around that these
extremists are going to try and pull
this off yep yeah on the fourth of july
no one's gonna know
because i was there there's a there's a
viral there's a viral story right now
this woman
who was at a party and someone dared her
to go across the street and steal this
guy's nazi flag
and she did and then he pulled out a
rifle and shot her four times
and then she was found by the cops lying
in the ditch crazy story
and one of the locals gave gave an
interview and he said
these are locals in a town that they
have guns and he says we couldn't we
know right away if it was a firework or
if it was gunshots so
you know we just went out to see what
was going on and sure enough you know
the police show up and there's a woman
mm-hmm so the first lesson that story is
don't go on other people's property and
steal their stuff
more importantly this guy got arrested
because you don't shoot someone who's
walking with a flag
yeah you know what she did and the guy's
the guy's crazy in the first place
the other thing i was saying is like
this story's nuts too because like
don't steal a flag from someone who's
clearly a nut case yeah like dude's
clearly a psychotic fascist that's a
good point and you're like gonna walk on
this property in the middle of it it was
it was a town of like 100 people oh man
yeah well i'm glad they arrested the guy
that's for sure seriously it's a
horrifying story
but the reason i bring it up is that
even the locals were like we weren't
sure if it was a firework or whatever
yep and that's interesting to me because
i think people in the country have a
better understanding
more likely to know hey that was a
gunshot right
so i guess uh well some people have
experience of what gun
shots sound like i know you do i know i
do so it's like i can
i know what a gunshot sounds like you
know that wasn't a gunshot
yeah right i was a lot loud bass yeah if
that was anything the closest it could
be was like a
what it was like a 44 millimeter are
they 40 or 44. i always mix them up
that was that was definitely like some
sort of like a tear gas canisters
something yeah yeah and and the kids
around here they're always
you know yeah you know there goes again
yeah
more fireworks going off there was a
funny post someone said uh because
la is canceling fireworks they were like
uh
as as i and my dog have have been
demanding
you know finally la will be canceling
fireworks something like that like my
dog has been demanding it
so many dog owners hate fireworks you
got to get them
you got to get them those harnesses that
are tight really snuggly yeah
their harnesses they wear they're
weighted and they squeeze them and it
makes them feel not scared i guess
that's interesting for whatever you've
never heard that yeah or cbd
but maybe maybe the fourth of july just
be a good old fun fun time and maybe
it'll be a good little day off but
there's gonna be that full buck moon i
guess
yeah it'll be exciting yeah full lunar
eclipse the moon's going to go out
completely
wow whoa that means it's going to be
pitch black outside yeah that makes me
real kind of nervous
it'd actually be a good good night for
fireworks oh yeah it'd be a good
night for anything it'd be a good night
to lurk in the shadows and
get away with some horrifying things
well it's america's day
and i have a feeling a lot of people are
going to be exercising their rights
on the fourth of july yeah isn't today
canada day today
birthday canada congratulations
congratulations canada i hope
i hope you can be proud to be canadian
they're not
that's not true no it's very
embarrassing they're putting up warning
signs
i know i know a lot of people that are
proud to be
canadian so leaders aren't happy well
i'm sad
i heard it directly from canadians there
are there are canadians that are proud
to be
no trigger warnings on their statues
then oh no i i saw those trigger
warnings there's
i mean the sjws are infecting everywhere
it's a disease it's spreading
it's worse it's not surprising thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you